donc ce que vous voyez là c'est les
affaires personnelles qu'il nous reste
encore à embarquer les livres voilà il
la bibliothèque lac est en train de se
vider derniers jours dans son ministère
pour nadia est nommé ministre délégué en
charge de la vie le 6 juillet 2020 par
jean castex évinoise né à traves a
quitté l'avenue de ségur la semaine
prochaine suite au remaniement
ministériel
ça fait un peu bizarre mais en même
temps c'est le
la règle et donc n'ont cessé dans une
certaine continuité évidemment de ce qui
a été fait j'ai dû faire mes cartons
quand j'étais parlementaire en beaucoup
beaucoup moins de temps pour prendre le
poste et la fonction du ministère de la
ville donc non c'est juste dans une
continuité évidemment sur le départ la
femme politique de 42 ans a participé à
son dernier conseil des ministres ce
mercredi 11 mai continuera à gérer les
dossiers présents sur sa table jusqu'à
la passation de pouvoir s'est vraiment
finir cette gestion courante et puis
surtout rester en alerte de tout ce qui
peut se passer puisque j'occupe ce poste
enfin cette fonction de ministre tant
que tant que la passion n'a pas été fait
donc il peut y avoir n'importe quel
alerte un dossier qui remonte urgemment
une décision à prendre aussi les des
parapheurs sur mon bureau qui attend de
ma signature donc il ya encore des
choses qui qui se passe au sein du
ministère pendant un an et dix mois
nadia est traité des centaines de
dossiers dans un ministère qui pèse 550
millions d'euros pour la politique de la
ville et 12 milliards pour leur
rénovation urbaine ce qui lui tient à
coeur la place des femmes dans la
société
levin was a notamment soutenu les gilet
rose une opération chiffrée à 2 millions
d'euros ce sont ces femmes courage qui
interviennent dans les quartiers qui
parfois aussi résonne certains jeunes
quand il ya des affrontements entre
police et population
ce sont des femmes aussi qu'ils ont
décidé de se retrousser les manches pour
aider d'autres femmes qui sont victimes
de violences conjugales qui sont aussi
parfois en manque de repères une fois
parti de son ministère nadia et
n'arrêtera pas pour autant la politique
l'ancien député sera de nouveau
candidate dans son département pour les
prochaines élections législatives en
juin mais cette fois ci dans la 7e
circonscription des yvelines